glow stringing and poi spinning sister
arts or one in the same the question
came up again recently and asking around
led me to the conclusion that
it's complicated let's take a look drex
here from drex factor poi sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
arts to benefit your body and brain in
this video we're going to take a look at
two movement arts that seem to have a
lot in common in first blush are they
the same thing are they not inquiring
minds want to know before we dive in
though i just want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
the trouble here starts a couple years
ago when i uploaded my video on what i
considered to be the six schools of poi
spinning which if you haven't already
you should check that out because i
think a lot of it is still pretty fire
even at the time i uploaded it there
were some people that wondered if i
might not have overlooked a school
why wasn't glow stringing on the list i
was reminded of this question a couple
weeks ago when it got posed again and
this time around i had reason to dig a
little deeper in lately i've actually
been finding myself on a bit of a
glow-stringing kick in that i've found
there are dance applications for the
style that i hadn't considered before
i'm in the process of learning many
glow-streaming techniques that weren't a
part of the poi spinning canon that i
learned in the 2000s and 2010s
and it made me curious why they weren't
part of the poi canon but i'm getting a
little ahead of myself here when i'm
referring to glow stringing what exactly
am i talking about i would define glow
stringing as part of the broader
movement art of blow sticking that is a
dance art usually associated with edm or
electronic music communities in which
dance and body movement are augmented
through the use of glowing props usually
in a rod shaped form factor this may
take the form of free handing in which
the props are held and traced around the
body in various ways or glow stringing
in which the props are attached to a
flexible tether such as a shoelace and
swung around the body in various ways
because this art is primarily practiced
at very crowded dance parties it favors
techniques that can be performed within
the body space of the performer or
within a very small bubble a few inches
out from their body from what i've seen
i'd consider glow sticking to be the
umbrella term for this overall movement
art and free handing and glow stringing
to be variations within it and right off
the bat we've definitely got some stuff
to untangle here
pun not intended because while some
aspects of glow sticking notably glow
stringing definitely seem to have things
in common with poi i'd argue that free
handing does not so while glow stringing
might be considered part of poi spinning
the broader umbrella of glow sticking
probably shouldn't be but this is the
first of what turns out to be many
complications as we look at the
relationships between these two arts
when i first learned poi in the late
2000s everybody i was learning from had
entered poi from the glow-stringing
world many had attended raves and had
picked up the art there their version of
poi consisted not just of weaves and
butterflies but also many different
kinds of wraps nowadays with rare
exceptions most of those wraps aren't
frequently performed by people who
consider themselves poi spinners but
techniques like spiral wraps orbitals
and gunslingers are all glow stringing
techniques that have become part of the
poi cannon and that many poi spinners
may not even realize have their roots in
glow stringing and a lot of glow
stringing as it exists now incorporates
flowers hybrids extensions and other poi
patterns that came to prominence and
popularity in the late 2000s and
continue to be popular to this day so
without a doubt there is a lot of
cross-pollination but are they the same
thing one thing that's clear to me in my
research on poi history is that the idea
of swinging around objects on strings is
something that emerges time and time
again throughout many cultures and
there's always at least a few things
that are discovered again and again
independently while many glow stringers
i've talked to on the topic from the
late 90s and early 2000s seemed to have
been aware of poi those who performed
the art earlier do not seem to have
either been aware of or been consciously
inspired by it for their own style
i think it's safe to say that at least
some of what glow stringing consists of
was likewise independently discovered i
actually took this question to the tech
glow stringing group on facebook and i
learned a lot of interesting history of
the art how it was refined over the
years and how it first emerged what i
did not get was a consensus on whether
or not it's poi spinning
and i think there's a good reason why
part of what makes this confusing is
that modern or contemporary poi spinning
is something of a creole art that's
taken pieces from many different
antecedents club swinging maori poi
spinning and yes glow stringing we use
the same name that is poi to describe
both the original maori art that ours
derives from as well as the contemporary
art that's been created out of this mix
so while many glow stringers correctly
say that their art is older than and has
influenced contemporary poi spinning
it is not older than poi itself i'll
also put some cards on the table right
now too because i think a big part of
this question comes down to consent
do glow stringers want to be seen as poi
spinners
here's why that question is important
at least to me every so often the
question comes up of whether poi is a
form of juggling and that question makes
me incredibly uncomfortable because in
many ways it feels like an attempt at
cultural colonialism and yes cis-head
white american dude who practices in
indigenous art i am fully aware of the
irony here
stick with me
also
pun once again not intended
i was aware of juggling for most of my
life and it was never a thing i was
terribly interested in learning my
exposure to poi was through fire dancing
then tech poi and finally the style of
poi dance fusion that i've been
exploring the past few years
my introduction to interest in and
continued pursuit of poi has never had
anything to do with juggling in any form
not only that at multiple points in my
career i've spent time around jugglers
who engage in shaming or looking down on
poi
it's too easy too flashy too silly what
have you
i don't get seen as a fellow movement
artist so much as an embarrassing
amateur who hasn't learned how to use a
real prop yet so when jugglers try to
tell me that they consider poi to be a
part of juggling i find the suggestion
not only completely misplaced but kind
of offensive
not only am i othered for spinning poi
within this community that wants to lay
claim to the movement art that i've
devoted myself to
there's not even a good reason to do so
other than a nebulous idea that juggling
should somehow be the umbrella term for
all prop based movement arts that
doesn't respect the cultural uniqueness
of the arts they're trying to lay claim
to there's a very colonial mindset going
on there in which jugglers assert a kind
of power and social control over someone
else's art
and in most cases
they do that not to offer a wider
community to be a part of but to
assimilate other arts and look down on
the people that practice them and caveat
here i have many close friendships with
many jugglers and i've seen some
juggling that i think is incredibly cool
this is a problem of groups and the
culture around them not of individuals
or the art itself this is a broader
topic for another time but suffice it to
say as someone who's been on the
receiving end of that treatment
it's really important to me not to do it
to others so the question to me isn't
whether i consider glow stringing to be
a form of poi but whether glow stringers
themselves want to be seen as poi
spinners and honestly from what i can
tell it doesn't seem like there's a
consensus around a strong desire to be
categorized as poi but there is to be
seen as a legitimate sister art and i
think that's important after all how
many of us as poi spinners have looked
at glow stringers the same way the
jugglers have looked at us as being the
lesser version of the art i'll confess
that until recently i definitely didn't
look at blow stringing as being as
involved as poi spinning i always found
glow sticks to be unwieldy on account of
their light weight and saw a lot of glow
stringers as being basically just raver
kids messing around and not as serious a
pursuit as my own work with poi and i
think that's a big part of why the
question came up
and perhaps a flaw in my methodology for
that original six schools video is glow
stringing an art that deserves our
respect yes absolutely
should it be considered a school of
modern poi spinning that's a little less
clear but it also reverses what the
relationship should be recognized as i
listed off maori poi as one of the
schools of poi spinning but that's not
quite right we are a derivative of these
arts in the same way that early rock and
roll comes about by playing blues with a
country beat behind it
it's not so much that glow stringing is
a school of contemporary poi spinning i
think contemporary poi spinning should
be thought of as the child art to both
maori poi and glow stringing and that
contemporary poi and glow stringing
continue to evolve and influence each
other so maybe a new schools of poi
spinning video would be appropriate one
that recognizes our antecedents rather
than trying to place contemporary work
alongside them and reduce their
contributions to merely being schools of
poi rather than inspirations for it and
maybe in the meantime we should be
asking not whether glow stringing is a
part of contemporary poi but whether
contemporary poi is a kind of glow
stringing
either way though whether a glow
stringer wants to also be called a poi
spinner that's up to them and i think
has to be thought of on an individual
basis
but for what it's worth i'm down to
welcome any glow stringer who does want
the title into the family
cheers
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help other people find this
video this video would not be possible
if not for the wonderful support of all
of these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to learn more about the history of
poi i have a playlist on that topic
available both down in the description
as well as up on screen if you're
watching on youtube also if you're
watching on youtube the algorithm thinks
you'll like this top video too if you
like this one
thanks so much for watching please make
sure to subscribe get outside and flow
today and i'll see you with a new video
on wednesday
take care